people who had mentors and coaches
experienced four times greater success
than the exact same person doing it on
their own
[Music]
talk about coaching uh it is something
that
is highly debated uh oddly
um and you see you know internet gurus
you see coaches
all over the place right and the
the reason i wanted to talk about this
is i think it's a super important uh
topic for a variety of reasons one is
why you know why is it important but
secondly
why do coaches get so much hate right
and so i wanted to uh
tell you what the data says what the
science says and so i was having a
conversation with dr cashie who some of
you guys know is a very close friend of
mine
um and he was saying that he had just
seen a paper that was a
mega meta-analysis of the impact of
coaching and mentorship
on success right on how people
are doing right and they found over 40
000
uh research studies and when they
consolidated all of the information and
they controlled for
income and you know iq and all of the
different things that could
that could uh make one person do better
than another people who had mentors
and coaches experienced four times
greater success than the exact same
person
doing it on their own all right and to
me
that seems like the most no-brainer
reason i mean why would you i mean
who wouldn't want to have four times
greater success or four times faster
results
um by having that right and
the thing is is despite knowing that
despite knowing that every professional
athlete and every olympian and every
every major
team has coaches for some reason the
general population or people at large
still have so much hate for them right
and you can if you've ever had any kind
of coach you can probably think back
and think like yes i was coaching with
this person and then many many times
people have a negative impression of
that person
who they worked with all right and so i
like to dive into these types of things
because i see like huge generalities
you know sweeping across the board um
and i'm by no means immune to this i
have tons of people that i've helped
you know go from broke to million dollar
plus gym that now
avidly speak against me um and i just
like to think like
what caused this right and so i was
reading um
i think it's 50 scientific ways which is
a phenomenal book by the way 50
scientific ways to uh persuade people or
to get the yes
camera word something like that it's one
of robert kealdini who is the
author of influence and persuasion for
both two of the best books on influence
and marketing and sales that exist
um so he's co-author of this book and
one of the chapters
highlighted uh something that i thought
was like a huge eye-opener for me
and it was that when doing a favor for
someone
all right and i'll show you how this
relates to coaching when doing a favor
for someone
the perception of the favor
and how important how big it was
actually correlates with time
and so immediately after you do a favor
for someone
the person who received the favor thinks
super highly of you because they were
just in pain and they're immediately
relieved from the pain
they were in and then at that moment is
when they believe what you did for them
to be of the of the highest
importance of them of the highest impact
on their life
then over time it just continues to
decline
right over time over time it continues
to go down of what their perception of
what your favor was and what it did for
your their lives now where this
gets interesting is that the perception
of the favored doer
of you right if you did the favor you
believe that the amount of effort and
the amount of impact it had on the
person's life
goes up over time and so immediately
after you you do something for someone
is the moment you feel
like it was it was nothing it wasn't a
big deal i just you know i just did this
and this
but the person who received it was like
oh my god this like i was stuck on this
for two years
and it was horrible and as soon as you
came in everything changed right
but if you revisit that same story six
months later
the person who got the favor is like
i mean i would have figured it out
anyways you know i'm a pretty i'm a
pretty smart guy i really wanted to do
it
if it wasn't that guy was someone else i
was gonna figure it out right it wasn't
that big of a deal
and then the person who did the favor is
like oh my god
i saved this guy's life and he doesn't
even blah blah blah right
whatever but the point is is that this
is a psychological bias
and it's it's just real it's just in
people and so in recognizing that it can
give you a little bit for me of solace
because i'm just like okay you know
what's what's going on here
um but it's just it's a it's a
scientifically proven
psychological bias that exists in all
humans and so i think that there's a
couple of
of takeaways that i've taken from this
and that you can too
um is that one if you
if you if you're doing any kind of
coaching right it could be fitness
coaching it could be
you know it could be you're being a doc
and i'm using coaching in a broad term
it could be mentorship it could be you
know what i mean it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be business related
it could be anything right is that
if you so this is purely just me giving
you the tactics by this
if you do someone a favor the time to
ask for a favor and return
is immediately immediately after you've
done the favor
because at that point is where they will
believe what you did
for them was of the most importance
right
now you can also get into probably
secondary effects of this which is
well if you can continue to do favors
over time right then you continue to
have those
those windows of of goodwill right
and i think of it like a telephone
telephone wire so if you guys under
old school i don't even know if of
course this thing is something telephone
or power lines where
you know there's a pole and then it dips
down and then there's another pole and
then it dip down and then it's another
pole
and just think of each of those poles as
the goodwill or the or the things that
you do to help
uh people out but if you don't do that
then it just continues to go down and it
touches the ground and then it you know
the wire blows up because of
whatever right and so um
i just find this really interesting
because favors i think also
act a lot like information right and
if you sell information like i do right
i sell a business model i sell sales
trainings i sell you know
how to how to generate customers all
that kind of stuff right is that
information
although incredibly valuable upon
consumption immediately decreases in
value in perceived value
to the person who consumed it and so
information is one of those
interesting things that is incredibly
value but declines in value very rapidly
all right and so this is why
if you are teaching people things you
need to consistently teach
new things on a regular basis so that
they can continue to have those
telephone poles
of over and over again you breaking a
belief or teaching a new thing or
whatever it is so that they can continue
to grow
and i do think that over time there's
some level of goodwill that gets built
um but still most people are functioning
on the what have you done for me lately
right and i just you can you can be
resentful of that and you can be the
favor doer who's like i changed this
guy's life
um or you can just deal with the reality
is that people don't care
right they'll just think about what you
did for them lately and so
i just see this as incredible like as as
statements of truth
and so then you can just act in
accordance with that it's like so if you
if you want you know you help someone
lose
25 pounds working with you then get the
testimonial
at that time right at that moment right
don't wait and then ask for it six
months later because at this point
they're gonna be like well i was gonna
join another gym
you know i was gonna probably do
something either way and it was really
me who's doing all the dieting i mean
yeah you know he helped
right whereas if you've done it right
after they get off the scale
and you tell them to come right in and
you do a great video they'll have all
the emotions they'll just have gotten
out of pain they'll have achieved their
their thing and the thing is they'll
probably far more accurately depict
how much of a change you really did in
their lives right
and so i think this has far-reaching uh
implications for a the psychology of the
coach
but also be the psychology of the coach
e right and i think that i've
experienced this myself with
different coaches that i've had
throughout my life recognizing myself
internally is like
you know i look back on what they did
and i think those same thoughts which is
like i would have done it anyway i'm a
winner winners win
um and i was gonna happen now whether or
not that's true doesn't really matter
the point is is that they were still the
one who helped me out right and so
you know giving respect to those people
i think has been something that
uh in the beginning of my career i don't
think i did
um as much as i do now and i think it's
partially just you know maybe it's age
maybe it's
experience maybe it's scar tissue you
know um
whatever it is but i have i think i have
probably in the last year or two
um been much better about giving massive
amounts of respect to the people who
helped me out
uh earlier on in my life and um and let
me give you a different framing as well
if you're the person who
got received the favor so i kind of
talked about this from the coaching
perspective but
talk about it from the from the student
perspective is that like in my book
which was released two years ago or a
year and a half ago whatever it is
um i have acknowledgements in the back
and i have
all people who influence me on that page
good and bad
because i still learn tremendous amounts
from some of the people who are what i
would consider maybe negative mentors
right i learned i learned what not to do
a lot of times
and still some of those people still
broke beliefs of mine even if they
weren't intending to
right and so i think tony robbins talks
about this where he says you know
blame them you can't just blame your mom
or your dad right for the insecurities
they gave you
also blame them for your resilience
blame them for your ability to
persevere blame them for all the
positive characteristics that you
developed as a result or in reaction to
some of the negative things that they
did
right and so i think that if you can
adopt that perspective
it's one way mentally healthier for you
two you won't burn bridges with people
who probably did help you at some point
and then three if you are the coach if
you recognize that this is going to be a
cognitive bias this is going to be a
psychological bias that's the need in
all humans
then you can adjust the way that you
fulfill your business or you fulfill
your coaching
which is one if you want to get someone
to recognize what you did for them you
want to have that done immediately or as
soon after they achieve their result
right and then secondarily you want to
continue to put
post up those telephone poles week after
week month after month so that
you don't have to have that information
decline over time
and the only way to do that is work
right
because it requires effort like we have
to continue to innovate we have to
continue to make things easier we have
to continue
to strive to solve the next problem
because the good news for everyone is
that every single student you ever have
as soon as you solve a problem a new
problem will be created
from the gap that you just that you just
bridged right they will just go across
the bridge to the next
plateau where there's another gap where
they need another bridge belt
and so as long as you've been farther
far ahead enough of the the people that
you are teaching coaching mentoring
student team
right um you will be able to continue to
build bridge after bridge after bridge
for those people and it will force you
to grow
as a as a coach as an entrepreneur as a
business owner as
as whatever right uh because you will
force to level yourself up so that you
can continue to provide value because
the value that you provided
has an expiration date so um i hope you
found that valuable hopefully that
interesting for me i think it was really
uh
once i kind of connected all those
pieces together uh it made a lot of
sense in my own life
uh for me as a student but also for what
i've you know experienced
uh as a as a quote coach or mentor or i
hate the word mentor but you know
whatever
um as a you know as a as somebody who
develops business models and helps
other people uh make more profitable
businesses it's been something that's
been very valuable
for me and honestly just very calming uh
to my spirit
and so anyways i hope that makes sense
to you um i hope you found that valuable
and if you did tag coach
uh tag one of your coaches take some of
your trainers tag some of your
friends family dogs pet higher power
whatever it is
um otherwise have an amazing day hope
you guys have a crushing tuesday and
i'll talk to you guys on the flip side
you